ricken overcome the circle strong
strong is the job
it couldn't be greater the risk today
but also the opportunities
because a lot is at stake if
europe is doing the right thing then we can
emerge stronger from this crisis
all the necessary parts for the
negotiation are now available  the table
and a solution is possible and
people in europe also expect a
solution from us because it is their
jobs
that are at risk they are
still exposed to the risk of the virus and
we will have to learn to live with the virus
and the whole world  observe
europe if we are able to stand up together
and overcome this corona-related
economic crisis
if we do it right then
we will have a convincing european
budget and we will
launch next generation eu not
only to get over the crisis
but  also to modernize the european union
to modernize our internal market  eren pushing the
european green deal
forward and digitization of the day
today is of incredible importance